[Music]  Rob Kardashian seems to be moving on  from baby mama blac chyna we're all in  the good place  maybe so but Choi's former fiance has a  new lady love in his life Bad Girls Club  star Megan James obvious on people I'm  Kim Kardashian's black sister because  like I'm just really pretty and I have a  good personality et can confirm the 30  year old businessman and the 26 year old  reality stars relationship is quote  pretty new and they've been casually  seeing each other for a few months now  rob was last seen cozying up to  ex-fiance blac Chyna in April and posted  a sweet throwback of the 29 year old  model to Instagram earlier this week  which he later deleted  you